in the center of seoul south korea  there's a neighborhood known as yongsan  most people had no reason to come here  it was a little rough around the edges  [Music]  [Music]  this is kim jung-gyu  he's the main guy leading the charge to  convince young people and small  businesses to open shop  to be part of passion island you have to  live locally and stay true to the spirit  of the neighborhood  [Music]  [Music]  this ongoing change has turned the  neighborhood from one of the scariest to  one of the coolest places in town  [Music]  this is a pretty radical business plan  in south korea  but these ideas are working passion  island is now the hip  foreign  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  you